[Music]
oh
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
all right welcome to uh ash wednesday
that's a [ __ ] my voice went oh all
right all right
which is horrible because of how
masculine our guest is it almost makes
me feel embarrassed to be here uh this
is being this is kind of news to a lot
of people but we'll have a new show
called fearless at the blaze hosted by
jason whitlock uh mr whitlock thanks for
being here sir good to be here good to
be in crowderland yeah i like this this
is the whole idea when we built this
studio was we wanted to be a space where
people would actually want to hang out
you know not like you know if you've
worked at espn it's almost like the
blazon saddles town where you get in
you're under the bright lights and like
get me out of here
that is true you got your own video game
i'm looking at stephen crowder yeah
steven crowder that was actually the
least expensive item
here yeah it was just some guy who made
it for us when i like all these other
people you know when they build sets
they'll build super expensive sets when
we uh remember we're first talking with
this company we're just hiring someone
as a consultant she's like oh okay well
we get like a neon sign i think we could
get it for you for fifteen thousand
dollars whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
she just said well we have a podcast
that i think it might have been espn
that has a pool table that's like i mean
i want to say something absurd like 50
000 and i just go well that's done these
bloated budgets are not going to exist
anymore when you have joe rogan in an
airstream kick in your ass pretty much
yes so um and you've been on on all
fronts well first actually uh i'm gonna
light this uh
you're gonna have to teach me how to
smoke a cigar yes okay which is
interesting because we were just talking
about when i go to a cigar lounge
it's 50 black people and then all the
white people are conservative but i
don't think all the black people are
conservative but i've never once seen an
argument at a cigar lounge it's just
kind of a great uniter where you can sit
talk have a drink calm down
i think that
probably everybody in there has
shared values
uh i think that many black people are
conservative
but
vote
democrat because they've been programmed
and trained that way but yeah a lot of
people my brother and his wife are into
cigars right a lot of athletes a lot of
my friends are into cigars i just i've
never been into it just but you know i'm
always willing to yeah there you go
we'll try something new all right so
i'll show you how to how to light it now
is i always i always feel like an idiot
whenever i'm teaching someone anything i
mean you have a lighter yeah yeah well
um
so and that's a torch later so we want
to do is toast the cigar
all the way around kind of see like you
want to toast the edges
if you get it lit the right way where
everything is lit
um
then you're not going to have burn
problems a lot of times you'll see
people just start like puffing on it
and what ends up happening is they don't
light the cigar evenly and it canoes and
it becomes a problem
here let me watch you doing it there you
go
yeah
but i don't i see your whole thing well
cc when you blow on it
and this has a soft flame so then i
and then once you light it once it's all
lit then you take a couple of drags you
know in from the flame you suck the
smoke in from the flame a little bit
yeah so now you put the put the flame up
to it flame up to the foot yeah now draw
on it
and kind of rotate it as you draw on it
there you go
and let me see real quick if you blow on
it blow on it you should see it should
all be lit and then you'll kind of see
the little black spots that's where
you'll light it a little bit more
yeah for people who are watching here
kind of on camera i'll show you
a lot of people send me they'll send me
requests like how do i light a cigar i
keep having problems there's an easy
trick is
blow on it once it's all lit
yeah and then you can just draw on it
and once you get it lit it'll be good
and i'll uh as you finish that i'll tell
a story here these are actually
they're from the wide shot
these cigars are uh bella sartes um not
an official sponsor by any means to the
show
but cigars are really are an item that
are finite like this i think is about
age seven years you can't just make more
of it like bourbon
and
i just pull i can't believe i'm not
coughing having pulled on this twice
really well you shouldn't be inhaling it
i'm not okay yeah i don't know this is a
really nice smooth cigar there too i
think you're
i think you're good and is the draw good
are you getting like you're getting
smoke through it
yeah looks good to me
all right there you go so we're all
we're all set now that we uh now we've
spent way too much time in this but let
me because i have to thank people out
there aj fernandez the people who uh
make these cigars i never wanted to
recommend them because like guns there's
a cigar shortage and so i knew if i
recommended my favorite cigar i wouldn't
be able to buy them so not a sponsor to
the show but he did say i'll make sure
that i can always send you a box so now
i can tell you uh belos artist is an
unbelieve it's it's my favorite i
recommend it very affordable i have lung
cancer tomorrow i'm blaming you
well i'm blaming you
blame all those years coal mining
what are you gonna blame me if you get
cte too
won't blame you for that but look i'm
glad you got me some casa dragonas too
that's it i'm sorry yeah i love this
tequila okay and so that's gonna help me
smoke this cigar and that
i think because again i'm a lightweight
i'm not a big drinker i'm not i used to
smoke weed in college but that was in
college a long time ago jason a long
time ago and so don't cigars give you a
little bit of a buzz a little bit but
it's more comparable to um like coffee
you know what i mean and if you inhale
it it'll make don't drink coffee well
i'm saying it's more of a mild stimulant
is that good
this cigar has made my tequila taste
even better well you know what that's a
big thing it's like pairings like wine
with cheese um so there and i'm not a
big drinker either my wife thank you so
much she bought me a bourbon oh that's
good that was like almost 100 i've never
had that in my life and i think now i'll
only ever drink hundred dollar bourbon
it's so much better
all right so mr whitlock
we had you on the show a while back and
the reaction was
like intense how much people liked you
um and the word that kept coming back
was authentic people really liked your
authenticity which
i mean is always a good quality but it
seems to be something that people
recognize with you and you know i've
talked about this before i think what it
is is we've talked about how you have a
lot of conservatives sometimes if
they're like black conservatives or gay
conservatives you know which are
atypical
um
a lot of times they come up to the ranks
and right away they have a show or they
have people think that they have
something to gain
when you came out with your views and i
don't want to say conserve as a
christian sort of you can say
traditionalist however you want to
define yourself i mean you stand you
stood to lose a lot and you did it
anyway and i think that's why people
really gravitate toward you
i hope that it's my authenticity and i
hope
that i would think there are people in
your audience or your audience there's a
lot of synergy
because one i've been in the sports lane
sports the values taught in sports are
pretty conservative
and so there's a great synergy between
sports fans
and conservatives what do you mean by
that because you know people will look
at like you know colin kaepernick and
what the nba that's the new sports world
okay okay
what sports have been for
more than a hundred years
has been a celebration of americana and
a representation
really of what america aspires to be a
meritocracy
colorblind
unifying i thought you were going to say
rich and black
because that's football and basketball
that is most white kids now if they
could be anything they want to be rich
and black they want to be that's they're
all trying to act like they're hip-hop
moguls they're athletes lebron you know
this kid every kid looks up them which
to me growing up
i grew up kind of on what we would
consider a post-racial america certainly
more so than today
i mean i had pictures i didn't even play
basketball just had pictures of michael
jordan on my wall you know what i mean
it was one of those it didn't really
matter it seemed like a meritocracy and
nowadays because people are so gun shy
i think
people are moving away from that
sometimes they're scared
well
we're cert i think
we're moving away from
our christian values in this country
and i've been on a little speaking tour
where i've been trying to explain to
people like you think cancer culture is
about conservatives or republicans or
donald trump or stephen crowder or jason
whitlock
what's being cancelled is jesus
the this whole
racial thing
is a way of moving people
away from their christian values
yeah and you're hitting people that are
trying to be beholden to their christian
values
and you're labeling them as racist
yeah
so now they're less likely to espouse
their christian values because they've
all been defined as racist
they you would think that black
americans are republicans when you look
at where they line up on things like
social issues you know a lot of the
social values and certainly they're the
moderate wing of the democrat party
today um but why do you think that why
do you think
that that sort of wedge
works with black americans when they're
you know predominantly compared to
white americans it's very secular
kind of the black american culture is
the one place where
most people would still identify as
christian but sometimes they buy this
stuff hook line and sanker well i think
it works because of our history
there has been a reason for
us to consider our race
as something that america uses against
us
and so
we have placed a higher value on our
skin color
uh
than we probably should
and we've certainly we've been
susceptible in this new era
to
identifying more as black than christian
we prioritize our skin color over our
religious faith and that's a mistake
and i think if you understand the
history of america
the african-american journey
has been the steroids for american
greatness and so if you go all the way
back to 16 1700s
the the sin of slavery
and
the black people's fight for american
freedom
made america live up to its best ideals
made america live up to what was
promised in the declaration of
independence and what's promised in the
u.s constitution and so
our history is something we should be
celebrating and not looking at as like
uh
that it damns america right we should be
looking at it like no no your history
made america great your pursuit of
freedom
made america live up to its best ideals
you're essential
to american greatness and we thank you
and have gratitude and respect for that
and
let's don't
cover this all with with shame and it's
damning of america
uh
you're essential especially too because
so many white americans shed blood to
make sure that we ended the unique sin
of slavery i mean a lot of people don't
realize this i was from uh you know i
was raised in canada i was born in
detroit raised in canada
and uh
when i started this show i guess about a
decade ago when i was on radio
um
someone called in and said something i
don't remember but they listed the year
and they said you know my so-and-so
grandfather i don't mean how many years
how many generations back said you know
fled to canada and i did the mental math
there was slavery in canada everyone
knows there's slavery obviously in the
english empire long after we abolished
it not in just britain but the not in
england but the british empire and i
said oh you know what they would have
said in canada if you fled there great
more slaves
because it existed there um
we did though we are singularly unique
in fighting a really really bloody
battle to end it um and and it's it's
one of those things that i think people
overlook when even they look at
jefferson or washington and people who
always saw it as evil this idea that it
was unanimously accepted look it was
unanimously unanimously accepted by
slave traders in africa for example was
a business that had gone on and it was a
way of life but a lot of people in the
united states always had a problem with
it
even people
like jefferson who owned slaves right he
knew it was morally wrong
and needed to be corrected and that's
why he wrote the declaration of
independence the way that he did you and
i think are both friends with glenn beck
have you ever seen glenn's got rough
drafts oh yeah from declaration of
independence yeah that show you what
jefferson really thought about slavery
but we couldn't get two of the colonies
to
sign and they couldn't free their own
slaves until death and so there's like
have you ever have you met david bart
you know glenn beckham with all the
historical documents oh man we i would
go there and he has this building where
it's you know basically hermetically
sealed humidity controlled and he has
all these old documents
and because i'm i'm often an idiot with
important things i'm always nervous like
if it's someone who's really important
or if it's an object of great historical
significance
um i always get nervous that i'm gonna
break it and he'd be like oh yeah this
is uh i don't know could be like this is
a jefferson's uh diary and this is one
of the original leathernecks that they
were you know they talk about the navy
and the marines where the terms come
from and actually fighting off islamic
pirates i'm like here you go and it'll
toss it to me
he has so much there it's like a batcave
of history um
i wanted to go back to something you
mentioned about sports kind of you know
conservative values and that kind of
goes to something that i've always said
this even if you look at uh rich white
liberals like in hollywood entertainment
industry they claim they're liberals but
they don't live like liberals in the
sense that they work really they just
feel guilty so they a lot of them don't
want to accept that their work ethic or
their skill their talent has brought
them success
let me ask you this when you how many
years did you play in the nfl i didn't
i did not play i played college well you
played sorry i played yes we'll see this
is how much i look i know nothing about
sports
uh but then you commentated obviously
i made my bones as a journalist so
college ball and you played five years
did you four you played four and then
they taught me five years to graduate
from college okay well i'm just kidding
i'm i'm oh for two uh but
the point is did you feel like you were
uh did you feel like people were
discriminating against you based on race
when you played college ball
did you know
uh
look did i see
some racist acts
as a college football player did i
experience some yes
uh you know
we had a black guy and a white guy on
our team
uh and i like both of them but they got
in a fight
with each other at a party and the coach
kicked the black kid off the team
and we all
erupted yeah i was like hey man this guy
was at the fight yeah you know this is
crazy and we got the guy reinstated on
the team was it like a mutual fight it
wasn't like a jumping or like that no it
was a mutual fight yeah it was a mutual
fight it was
and and
look i like both of them i'm i'm still
friends with both of them today 30 years
later uh but we erupted like hey man
this is bs and they had to let the
andre back on the team look i i we
played against i won't name the kid's
name but we played against the team that
uh the defensive tackle that i was
blocking the whole game
called me the n-word throughout the
entire game and i just kept looking i
knew guys on the other opposing team
yeah has he seen you
well
it doesn't seem like a smart move it
wasn't but
he's a defensive player i'm an offensive
lineman oh so you wouldn't meet up yeah
and but no we were playing each other
against each other i was blocking him
and i would look over at his teammates
on the other they played for northern
illinois i look over his team i was like
what is this clown doing
because he's on the defensive side it's
a more black side of the ball he's
huddling up with if there's eleven
defensive guys probably eight of them
were black and i'm like
one thing that i will say that white
hockey players got right no other sport
has this you know i've talked about this
i don't know how much you know about
rockstar
yeah exactly and the ref lets it go
they've changed it now yeah but uh
actually a friend of our family
hopefully won't mind i've talked about
him before stu grimson really solid
christian we actually met him at a place
called hockey ministries camp where it
was for often underprivileged youth
or they would have like grants where
kids could go and they would do bible
study and then they would also do hockey
practice and uh stu grimson came in and
he was an enforcer in the nfl
and uh that was his only job yeah this
thing keep going out it's because it's
because you're talking it's okay i don't
know um
but you know what there's some there's a
beauty to that it's sort of
self-governance where if this guy was
calling you the n-word you know in
football if you could have had a uh ref
tell you to all right drop that we're
not gloves but take off the helmets and
go
that would have been a lot better i
kicked his ass the whole game did you
have my okay
yeah i got my get back and we beat him
and
you know but but
yeah
no place
on the planet is perfect
unfairness is a part of the world
racism is just a derivative of
unfairness yeah it's just this form of
unfairness
it's not going to go away
ever
you ca i cannot lose this argument
though no country has created documents
like
the declaration of independence and the
constitution and a system of governance
that combats unfairness right better
than america and that's all you can do
and that's the biggest concern when you
look at all great civil rights movements
whether i mean whether you're talking
about uh race or gender equality the
whole suffrage movement we can go
another women i'm glad you got the right
to vote without having to do mandatory
draft bucket duty or pay taxes okay and
we voted for that a little bit different
from civil rights but they all were um
they were spurred by
speech
the first amendment you know these
everyone whether you're black or white
and some people try to abuse that but
ultimately these constitutional rights
are what allowed marginalized people to
speak out raise awareness and like you
said fix the unfairness tip the balance
back and now you have a movement
white black i would just say it's really
more so about elites versus us the
plebes americans who want to make sure
that you can't speak and if you can
speak and they say well it's not a first
amendment issue they want to make you
afraid to speak and they'll do it with
you by calling you an uncle tom like you
said and they'll do it with me by saying
well you're a racist
so i guess we're two peas in a pot a
racist hosting an uncle tom i don't know
how that happens a racist wouldn't be in
a room with an uncle i just you know
but this is where we are now and once
you take that away and
right now obviously black people enjoy
equal rights in this country but who's
the next marginalized community if you
take away speech right now you're
talking about i mean for example taiwan
or the people of hong kong right these
are people who need americans to speak
out for them and even though it's not
against the first amendment the nba has
put more we can't speak about hong kong
you know we just had john cena who's
all-natural by the way
john cena apologized for acknowledging
taiwan as a country because of pressure
from a communist chinese government and
big tech who are willing
to appease them i really am concerned
that um there are going to be people in
positions of power who can pick
what new civil rights movements
are allowed to take place which
marginalized communities are allowed to
speak taiwan no you don't get to people
of hong kong no you don't get to hamas
good get in the car
you started this
by saying
white liberals
preach one thing but what they actually
do for themselves contradicts what they
and and the biggest thing i see what
drives me craziest
is the white liberal
with an
ultra commitment to his family or her
family yeah and
they're basically telling
black people
family doesn't matter to you we got a
government check
ignore that 75 80 of your kids are being
born into a single-parent home ignore
all that we got a government program
that's going to fix that head start is
going to fix the fact that there's no
daddy in the home right that ain't the
way they're living they're not sitting
they are committed to their families
and will keep their families intact
despite whatever dysfunction may be
going on daddy may be cheating mama
might be cheating but we're gonna keep
this family together for these kids
they have the commitment to their and if
there is no family structure trust me
you're not going to grow roses from that
you're not going to grow success from
that and so it's like they're sentencing
us black people
to a dysfunctional family
that can't produce
properly functioning supportive
neighborhoods communities
nations anything
that's that's the hypocrisy they know
family
is the key to everything
but they want to tell us now you know
what the key is
stopping these
lightning strikes of police killing
black men right there that's lightning
killing getting struck by lightning and
dying happens as often as what we saw
happen to george floyd
god rest george floyd's soul this is
where i drive people crazy because i've
had a family member who i helped raise a
cousin
killed by police in indianapolis in 2012
in what we believe was an unjust fashion
i get it i know that pain i'm not
speculating i know it
but that happens so rarely right
it's it's like lightning striking and
killing somebody
but
family breakdowns that create
generational dysfunction yeah
we need to focus on that my dad was
alive and still running the masterpiece
lounge the coronavirus would have
destroyed his business and his way of
life he ran the masterpiece lounge the
masterpiece lounges neighborhood bar in
indianapolis that's exactly the kind of
business i would expect a black man to
run
the masterpiece lounge you ran it rises
me zero do they have cigars in there
when they're not probably not towards
the end yeah
but it was look it was my favorite place
on earth it's in the inner city in
indianapolis it's it's it's why it
doesn't mat how much every money i've
made or will make in the future i'm
always going to be a masterpiece lounge
person yeah uh and like working as it
caters
yes still there i sold it to somebody
else and okay they they run it or maybe
they've sold or someone else but it's
still there i'd love to go visit it at
some time we could go do a walkthrough
and see if it's like you know it used to
be if you remember it's
well i know the guy sort of too
invested some money in it but yeah it's
still in the same neighborhood it's it's
in the hood in indianapolis it's not far
from where my dad built a brand new home
in the inner city
it's it's god forbid it became an apple
beast yeah and i know it is it ain't
that you know it's still the man and we
man we had a backyard where we
cook and grill and i used to i've taken
like when the final four would be in
indianapolis i'd invite all the media to
come eat and drink at my dad's bar i'd
feed him drink them we'd cook the whole
nine yards it's it's no look it's a
black version of cheers
uh and then occasionally once or twice a
year whenever there was a big event in
indianapolis i'd bring in all the media
all my friends in the media uh and they
get to see
what this is how we do it yeah in the
inner city of indianapolis and people
loved it the food's great they're going
to met yeah that's what's for real
i mean that strong sense of community
that you definitely get
more in the black community than you get
in the white community and the reason
for that is because look people use the
term black and white sort of
interchangeably and this is where i have
a problem with anyone who's actually a
white supremacist is i go when people
say white culture look
you shouldn't be browbeaten or be
ashamed to be white because it's not
something you can control but there is
no real white american culture because
there's irish american culture there's
italian american culture there's polish
american culture whereas black american
culture historically there is more of a
unifier
because like you said of how they were
discriminated against in in a similar
way so there is that strong sense of
community and culture which i think a
lot of white people are envious of
and i think a big part of that comes
from you look historically like you said
strong family units with black families
um i need to give you this this book i
actually think dave has it right now the
joe lewis uh biography that's my dog his
name joe lewis just because not only
joel is my favorite athlete ever i don't
think his title defenses and the
heavyweight division have ever been
topped
but um
a quote from him that i loved in that
book you know he grew up in he grew up
in the south
then he moved to detroit you know people
think he's from detroit but he's not
really from detroit that's where he
trained
he said maybe i was ignorant to it but i
grew up in the south it was yes sir no
sir ma'am he said i didn't experience
racism there like people talked about i
had met racists
he said but nobody called me the n word
until i moved to detroit
and uh that was a shock and what was you
know muhammad ali called him an uncle
tom joe lewis because he was beloved by
white america joe lewis was the most
popular athlete in the country we talk
about sports and race
i think this is something a lot of
people miss and this is why joe lewis to
me is is and you can you know tell me if
i'm way off base could just be my white
privilege but think about joe lewis
fighting max schmeling so max schmeling
was sort of they propped him up it was
like real life rocky iv right he was the
aryan sort of example
first fight joe was having them he lost
he was the only fight he'd ever lost
then joe lewis contrasts muhammad ali
you know who who ducked who ducked a
draft and obviously was a conscientious
objector and that was a different story
but it's it's interesting because it's
so antithetical to what happened with
joe lewis second fight max smelling a
lot of people don't know this joe lewis
i think only a couple weeks later
was going into world war ii he wasn't
exempt because he was a celebrity so he
was about to go into world war ii he's
about to fight the guy who hitler is
praising max schmeling the example of
aryan strength that will defeat defeat
the negro american you know back then
and uh
he got called by the president said you
gotta you gotta win this one you gotta
win this one for us it was the biggest
sporting event in history at that point
imagine the pressure on his shoulders
and he knocked out max schmeling
and all americans cheered and he was
america's champion
do you have individual racists sure
that's not a racist nation
i'm gonna go a step further because
jesse owens just i think in 1936
berlin olympics
he basically plays a similar role as joe
lewis
dominates
at the olympics in berlin in front of
hitler
becomes a national hero joe lewis two
years later 38 knocks out max spelling
national hero and
what what people
there's nuance to racism
my dad
did not like white people
you could call him a racist and he
wouldn't bat an eye
he
his life experience things he
experienced made him not like white
people yeah my dad
one of my favorite human beings to ever
be created i idolized my dad
i never
in my life
saw my dad act in a racist fashion
towards white people
and so
there was something
that trumped
his racism in terms of his engagement
sure and it was like because like a lot
of people they just want to be good
people right more than they want to be
racist
they want
whatever interest whatever energy
someone gave my dad he gave them that
same energy back yeah so if
you greeted him with respect
he's going to give you respect yeah if
you came into his bar he's going to give
you respect he's a businessman so i
lived a different life than my dad i
played high school football with jeff
george and on an integrated high school
team that was nationally ranked we won
the state championship i had
plenty of white friends growing up
my dad never now again he might
privately say to me i don't ever want
you dating a white woman and blah blah
blah but when it came time to engaging
interacting with any of my friends
it was always respect none of my friends
ever felt
his racism yeah it's because he wanted
to be a good person and so we have this
little silly belief
that if
someone says something
racist
that explains all of their actions every
like oh my god he says something racist
therefore every act he takes is a racist
actor he he's trying to advance the
cause of white people over black people
it's just not true yeah people are
really complicated they think and say
really stupid things
there are some things i have done in my
life i am so ashamed of there have been
moments where i have said things that
would cast me as a racist
anybody that knows me like man jason
we're like ain't racist right but have i
said some things have i done something
i bullied a kid a white kid in high
school oh you white boy punctum
it wasn't even about that it was more
about he
i was a football player and again we
played on this great high school
football team
i was the captain of the team this kid
wouldn't we all donated 10 or 20 bucks i
can't remember what the standard was
everybody on the team to buy the coaches
gifts at the end of the season we win a
state championship with a toast of
nationally ranked toast of the high
school this kid was on the team gets a
nice little state championship ring he
wouldn't give me the 20
for the coach he said if the coaches
what have they done for me
so that probably happened in let's say
november
the rest of the school year from
november until
june i bullied the [ __ ] out of this kid
any time i was a white king white kid
yeah it's reprehensible i still think
about it today because i i'm embarrassed
to say
a couple of the things that i did
bullying him because it it will make me
cry but you didn't even but you didn't
bully him because he was white you
bullied him because you thought he was
wrong but people could take that out
because he was white yes yeah and that's
a that's something really interesting
too because right now other people will
copy paste your motives they'll say oh
he bullied him because and certainly if
it was a white guy bullying a black kid
you would never
ever like my brother actually he only
got into one fight in his life
and we were raised in a essentially that
you bring this up
because if you meet my brother he's the
opposite of me he's
what's actually funny is i'm more of an
introvert i'm more shy but i make up for
it by talking with people whereas my
brother's actually more social but he's
very quiet
um certainly not aggressive
and
there was a guy
there were only about three black kids
in his class and one of them
happened to be
a real piece of [ __ ]
he was a bully he had bullied my brother
all year and here's what happened my
brother
my parents unbeknownst to me when we had
turtles and my parents didn't like them
because they were gross they carry all
kinds of diseases
so my parents allowed them to be the
class
pet
and we came into class one day and my
brother's turtle was a class pet in the
aquarium
and uh he was upset about it but what
happened is then the teacher said we're
gonna allow someone to take the class
pet home on the weekend a new person
each weekend which was not supposed to
be the rule
so this guy who bullied him black kid
hated my brother
took uh took the turtle home and then
put him on top of his remote control car
and drove him around and showed my
brother like pictures
the next fire drill when they're going
down the stairway my brother grabbed
this guy i can't say we have to bleep at
his name
um
my brother who had never ever been in
any kind of an altercation at all
pinned him and people could see because
head was dangling over the top of the
stairway my brother just started
pummeling him over his turtle
they were friends after that and the
thing is i was friends with that kid's
little brother who was also black but we
all knew that that guy wasn't he was the
family i guarantee you today that would
be seen as a racial issue it was that
his turtle was being put on a remote
control car and he was a kid and he felt
powerless you know what can he do the
teacher wouldn't do anything so he just
got into a fight and i just think of how
scary that must be to navigate now as a
kid like you said there are things you
look back on that you might
cry over
because you feel like you did something
wrong
i have those moments
and i think again it gets to godlessness
there's no forgiveness now we're looking
to score a point and define someone by
their their biggest moment of weakness
or
of you know sin
and we don't we we selectively forgive
people
that's really scary imagine being a kid
today
you know that would be all over
instagram
and we're now
looking at each other
as
father
or
a body to throw on a pile that we can
stand on and make ourselves bigger and
so
we
and i don't want to
send the conversation spiral in a
different direction but i'll just say it
but
take
derek chovin yeah i believe his actions
were criminal and wrong
i don't think
it was driven by race no and
uh i think most people
can understand that and
the reason why it's been racialized
because oh that'll make you popular over
social media right that will drive likes
and retweets and blah blah blah but if
you actually
watch the trial
race was no part of the trial yeah in
his so
even the people the lawyers in court
knew
that race isn't an issue here but the
entire media
has made everybody think this was a
racial case of police brutality and it's
just a case of police brutality a guy
chauvin that handled the situation
improperly yeah that's all it is i don't
know how you call that racist but that's
how once they frame the argument then
everything that is on one side is racist
and everything that's on one side is
altruistic
and i tell you what i hate to ever be a
pessimist but like we've talked about
sort of all fair without without god in
the middle i don't know there's any
coming back from from this
well
jesus god is the only solution and like
if you really understand
what
christianity
religious faith is it's a pursuit of
truth yeah
and
there they have effectively illegalized
the truth no and that's why
again if
i'm saying
jesus is the truth the truth will set
you free
the truth
powers
freedom yeah and so we're all sitting
here wondering why man we feel less free
in america than at any time and that i
you know for for as a black person
this feels like 1963
before the civil rights act of 1964 we
have less freedom now and the only way
to do that is to illegalize
truth yeah and the search for truth and
if if in trying to understand the truth
of what went on with covert what went on
with derek chauvin there are some
uncomfortable insensitive questions that
have to be asked debated analyzed they
can't be illegalized oh my god if you
ask that question you're racist if you
don't agree with our
take that it's first-degree murder or
second-degree murder or third because i
think most reasonable people in my view
think derek shoving should have been
convicted of manslaughter
i don't think
there's
if we had followed the truth wherever it
led i don't think it leads to
second-degree murder no and
and people need to be allowed to say
that without being oh my god
what an uncle tom and sell out he does
because here's another truth now i'm
just sorry
we may 25th 2021 was treated
damn near like it was
the day martin luther king or john jfk
were assassinated right jfk martin
luther king
i can't remember the day abe lincoln got
assassinated but these guys have resumes
of work of accomplishments
things they did stood for
uh
contributions to american society
no i'm sorry
uh
other than nine minutes i don't know
what
george floyd contributed to american
society we know how he harmed american
society and including his fellow
black members of his community with
armed robbery
um not being there as a present father
and i feel it doesn't mean that any in
any way that it justifies
someone dying at all but again if you
don't look at the truth
um if you try and amplify the lie as a
truth you miss the actual truth and then
you go one step further and the biggest
companies that have ever existed
feel that they've been given license to
remove truth something else too going
back to you know even jesus christ
jesus christ was killed for what
speaking
he was killed for words
he didn't actually commit any crimes and
his words were truthful or he said i am
that's what it was he was executed for
speaking truth this isn't new
and that's why
i'm trying to
and it's one of the reasons why
i partnered with the blaze
it's one of the reasons why i want
to continue our engagement you should
partnered with it sounded like you said
parted with the blaze partner yeah
partnered with partnered with the player
and why i want to continue to engage
with you
glenn beck
is that we need to
believers
and people with platforms
we have to host a discussion
so that we can expose to other believers
who are being fooled by this whole
racial warfare
to understand the war is actually
against jesus christ yeah and we need
you
to
choose a side and to
give in to your religious beliefs and
never lose sight of them because they're
trying to blind you with race so you
can't see the truth right and the
destruction of truth is the destruction
of jesus and it's why our country is in
the kind of chaos that we're in it's
it's
i i don't
it's been 60 years since we've been in
this type of chaos and to me
it's
i grew up i was born in 1967 one year
before mlk was assassinated i made
at that time because of the progress
that was made i was born into what i
believe was a very hopeful generation my
parents
were telling me and my brother and my
step-sister and step-bro you can be
anything you want you can accomplish
anything and that kind of belief made it
possible for barack obama who's just a
few years older than me to become
president of the united states yeah and
then to see in the aftermath of that
we've spent the last four to five to six
years
telling black kids man this systemic
racism you can't do [ __ ] in america
right yeah
i'm like what yeah i was in 1984 uh
stephen
me and my dad were in a 400
square foot one-bedroom apartment in the
hood yeah i slept on the couch he slept
in the bedroom
and
in 2020
i live on the wilshire corridor
in the richest strip of land in america
you have to brag about it
but i'm just saying no i know the
american dream is out there and
available if my little chubby ass
well come on being little you're being
generous here
if if i can get it
and i'm just
i can show you my s.a.t scores i can
show you my gpa in high school and
college
i'm not some genius i didn't go to some
ivy league school i went to ball state
yeah and
it can be got yeah and we shouldn't be
filling young people and kids up with
this belief like they can't get it here
in america yeah there's so much
opportunity
if you just lean into the values that
have always served us yeah and you know
what's funny so i i was born in 87. and
i tell you what
these shows that we watched
family matters urkel fresh prince of
bel-air
cosby yeah you know the rape kind of put
a damper on it but it's factual though
yeah no the co but cosby was huge um and
then of course uh i mean uh will smith
was the biggest star when i was growing
up
we didn't even think about it and when
you look at this today i've talked about
this i don't think you'll ever have that
again because now what do you have
you have tbs and tyler perry and it's
marketed toward black people
and then you have sort of white people
content
right there isn't 20 million people
tuning in to fresh prince and a majority
white people now it's fragmented where
it's like okay this is your
entertainment and this is our
entertainment um and and we didn't i
didn't grow up with that um and actually
one thing so i want to get into sort of
uh
the history of black comedians but one
thing that you said last time you were
on the show and i honestly think you put
a more effective finer point on it than
anyone did and it's going to sound like
i'm bragging because you sort of paid me
a compliment
but um i think it
required an outside lens like yourself
an outside perspective
to for me to be able to say yeah hey i
can't say that's a white guy but you
said you know people have gone after you
saying that that joke is racist he said
in my experience people who know that
they are not racist
are not nearly as mindful of trying to
say the politically correct thing all
the time because
they don't have any worry that they're
racist in other words if you tell a joke
about a white guy about an asian guy
about a black guy he said people who are
authentic
don't fear
racism around every corner and i thought
yeah you know as a comedian growing up
um you know when i was 18 i remember i
did an all black show one time i opened
for a guy named bruce bruce speaking of
people you know bruce bruce was black
boy two eyes bruce bruce and myself
um
and it was just in common it was just
like look you're funny or you're not and
of course when i was there it was
nothing but racial jokes the kind of
jokes i couldn't tell at an audience
outside of bruce bruce nor would i want
to but i realized i was so out of place
as a white guy that they were going all
right what do you what do you got
acknowledge that this is a little bit
off here
and at no point did anyone say well that
was racist it was it was something that
was just okay we're all being authentic
here and i think that's an important
point i think the people who are
inauthentic who maybe do harbor some
kind of racism are the ones who try to
put on a front that well you can't say
this and you can say that
and i think there's no more pure example
of this than comedy people are going to
get mad here what i'm about to say
but if you look at the sort of new trend
of all female comedians you know uh a
lot of they're not very funny yes thank
you doesn't mean that women can't be
funny one of my favorite comedians ever
uh kathleen madigan
one of the most in one of my biggest
inspirations ever joan rivers who i
watched when i was a kid and i watched
her edit just for laughs gala changed my
view of comedy but back then it was
you better be good
now
this is how i explain it to you if you
have an open mic night right with
amateurs in comedy let's say you have 10
spots
40 white guys sign up right you're all
competing for those spots
15 white girls sign up 15 15 women black
white whatever
you're gonna have five and five five
women and five guys
and guess what you're pulling from a
shallower talent pool
that's why
women aren't as funny typically when you
watch a special with women because they
go look we need 50 female comedians you
know where you don't see that
black people black people have always
been some of the best if you look at the
top comedians of all time you'd be
hard-pressed to find someone say anyone
else other than richard pryor maybe
carlin and then write down that list in
the top five you're gonna have dave
chappelle you're gonna have chris rock
you can have eddie murphy
because it wasn't we need five black
comics it was these guys are really
funny and when you look at you know like
we talked about the black community and
really a strong
history of passing down orally history
you look at black church right versus
white church you look at how black
people interact with movies it's a very
verbal culture
that's a beautiful thing to me and it
lends itself to high high quality comedy
but if back then we were saying we need
x amount of black people
i don't know that richard pryor would
have been richard pryor
i certainly know he wouldn't be richard
pryor in this environment oh culture we
have there's no way and and
you've hit on
my
because i've been doing some stand-up
at
open mics at zany's in nashville really
yeah just because i think comedy is
important i think that's up to you
though that's that's scary to do yeah
it's gone well twice i bomb really bad
once uh it happens
but but
it's because i believe there's two
things that can fix this one we've got
to return to christ and our christian
values but comedy
is important yeah for the protection of
free speech comedians and ministers are
the two people that are supposed to say
unvarnished truths yeah that
unvarnished truth is hilarious
it's thoughtful it's it's what has
carried comedy and we can't do it
anymore it's being illegalized and so
it's like
the reason why i've
i've got a little bit of a comedic part
of me but mostly it's just like i got
the balls i could care less
and i'm not going to let people because
i'm looking at dave chappelle get
stopped dave chappelle is not remotely
woke not in real life not remo he lives
in rural ohio
in a mostly white community he's married
to an asian woman
that's intentional trust me uh because
there's a way he wants to be treated and
respected as a man let's circle back to
that but yes and and so
dave chappelle's not woke and i'm
looking at him pretend to be when he's
going after candace owens yeah and that
special that was pretty rough yeah and
just all of it he's not saying what he
really thinks because there's so much
funny stuff happening on the left side
that these comedians black comedians are
leaving on the table i'm gonna give you
an example because this is what my whole
little comedy routine is based off the
last season of the bachelor
i didn't yeah i don't yeah we took an
attractive white woman who went on
national tv and said i want to have sex
with a black man for the rest of my life
and we labeled her races because she
wore a dress
at a party
when she was 18 or 19 years old she's
from the south and again i'm of a
generation
back
when i was a kid interracial dating was
a big deal it's nothing now it's nothing
now but for a woman from the south go on
national tv in pursuit of a black
husband her daddy's watching that her
mama her friends everybody's watching
that and she's on the show crying she's
in love with a black man and oh she went
to some party where she wore a sun dress
uh and you know so therefore she's
racist i'm looking at uh what's the
what's the black dude's name that was
the the bachelor's dad i can't think of
his name i don't know but i i'm like
looking at him like he's suspect because
any place he says any black dude i know
would be like hey baby uh bring that
dress over here to my house don't have
no panties on and we're gonna play buck
in the big house
all right enough to ask you about that
off air but
cultural differences i guess
you guys have that's the one thing i
might say what do you mean you guys i
mean black people you guys have all
these interesting terms that white
people don't have will you say bucket
and bit house buck in the big house
[ __ ] the big house see we just say we
just we just have sex regular
white people but again the big house is
is
is is kunta kente
where master's out of town and he's in
the big house okay
that's about what i figured
and oh my gosh this is gonna we're gonna
get letters for this look it's con it's
context over content so for example we
did a sk if you at any given moment you
might see something that if you don't
understand the context in the studio you
go that's horrifying one time i'm doing
an interview
and behind the interviewer there's
someone rushing in in a kkk outfit and
rushing out and i'm like if someone saw
this out of context first off it's an
asian intern
we were doing this sketch
the context is this
uh of the sketch and maybe at the time
that we're running this maybe it's
already aired that i don't know if you
know this about the kkk but like
grand exalted cyclops is a term or like
the the grand wizard all these and we
were sitting there one time we were
writing bits you know comedy and we said
do you think these guys were all just
like dungeons and dragons nerds and they
didn't want people to know it so they
just faked they were racist because it
was less embarrassing so we did a whole
sketch of clansmen who were trying to
play dungeons and dragons but the wife
going what are you guys you guys playing
dungeons and dragons down there no we're
hating blacks in the jews
and the context is they're not racist
it's but the point to it is to
absolutely belittle and mock the kkk to
render them powerless because they're
stupid terms and people who are in the
kkk are stupid people and i don't mean
like stupid like cool i mean stupid um
and that's a way to make a point
to mock the kkk because guess what if
you come out and say the kkk is bad no
one listens we all know that but if you
get a few million people laughing at
them ooh that gets racists actually mad
that's the power of comedy and they've
stripped
comedians of the right
and what am i mean to say right of the
right not
right no political view they've stripped
them of the right
to ridicule
and
undermine the influence
of the legitimate racist bigots on the
left yeah
and they
take colin kaepernick this is one of the
things that got me in trouble with fox
sports i wanted to do a spoof of colin
kaepernick in 2017 i believe early yeah
i want to be like now we need to expose
this guy and the funny thing is if you
need to do a parody of colin kaepernick
you probably can't find a black guy to
play him you probably have to find like
an egyptian dude or something i found
it was chris reed from kid and play oh
okay the rapper he's half black half
white african as i call him uh and i
don't say i'm not trying to be derisive
or whatever i got a lot of it's funny
who cares yeah i got a lot of
half black half white friends but anyway
i wanted to
spoof colin kaepernick to show the
idiocy and just like he's not because
the spoof was based off the fact that
nessa his girlfriend was actually
controlling him colin kaepernick is just
a symbol and so it was like
uh have you i don't know how much
college football you watch but none uh
they hold up signs on the sidelines with
pictures of like it'll be one big
billboard and have pictures like eight
different people and it's a signal into
the quarterback of what play to call and
so his girlfriend nessa was all i would
ask kaepernick a question and his
girlfriend nessa would hold up a sign
signaling in the rest give him the
answer
okay that's funny yeah it's a funny bit
yeah they wouldn't let me run it oh no
on
because the whole little twitter
universe
got an uproar because i tweeted out a
picture of kid with a kid from chris
reed with the kaepernick afro on and a
jersey yeah and me and i said look who
stopped by the studio today
just that picture alone was enough to
set the
twitter lynch mob off and enough to
cause the executives to get skittish and
fold and so this is like i wanted like
hey man we need to start ridiculing
colin kaepernick early because this
clown's going to have an amazing impact
if we don't yeah guess what when when
you have these black activists out there
like colin kaepernick would say we need
white allies
you don't want white allies because you
don't want white people to comment on
anything black
unless it's exactly the opinion that's
acceptable
otherwise you'll label it racist and so
white people are afraid to speak out so
they're afraid to be allies
and look this is important like i was a
perfect example of this not even on the
race side but the gender side
it shocked me when you look at men
playing women's sports
male to female transgender athletes
most women are now against it but they
support it for a long time the one
demographic who said no we don't think
that transgender male to female should
be a lot of women in sports
we're men
guess what we don't have a dog in that
fight
because female to male 1 are not going
to come in and dominate men's
weightlifting or men's wrestling
but feminists have said if you have a
penis no opinion
so now
now men can't help women
and so they get their ass kicked in
women's sports it's the same thing when
you make people afraid to speak out and
speak the truth you lose allies
you lose allies and you
promote
chaos disorder dysfunction you have
everybody at each other's throats again
if you eliminate the truth
you're setting
everybody up
to be at each other's throats
and to want to destroy each other
and that's why
comedians and ministers i believe are
the two most important
groups now broadcasters those of us with
some kind of
public influence third
but but ministers and comedians are
supposed to create the room for the rest
of us right speak truth
and it's just not happening ministers
have become very political
and uh it's it's obama and the black
church is
higher than jesus
and
uh dave chappelle has i'm looking at
dave chappelle chris these guys got
plenty of money
why can't i don't understand why they
just don't they got f you money right
why don't they act like it it's
bothering me the the thing that because
of legacy
like chris rock you saw his comment
where he said
you know he made a good point listen
when you look at with comedy we don't
need people to cancel us
you have a built the audience will let
you know
the audience will let you know you're
saying you know better than the audience
and now some people will say you're
doing black voice like that's black no
it's a chris rock it's chris rock but he
said that and then he said but you know
you might need to change with the times
like he was afraid to say it
i'd agree with you about legacy because
let's say chappelle or rock
hopped on and just started going with
the truth
then the left that's in control of the
media when they put out their little
list of the greatest comedians or
whatever
chris rock and dave chappelle are going
to fall
and then it's going to be written that
oh my god they decided with the right
wing racist and right they're trump
supporters and they're this and that
and
and now their legacy has been tarnished
and so all these guys and their kids
have to live with that legacy right and
so if their kids punch their name into
google and it comes up that dave
chappelle hated black people and was
uncle tom and dave don't want his kids
looking at that
i get it but at some point
and this is why i keep making this
appeal i was like this you got to stand
on jesus man and quit worrying about the
history that a group of idiots and power
corrupt immoral people are going right
and what about what jesus thinks
and your eternal life and and look you
don't believe in that
and and so god help you but yeah you
know i certainly do yeah and a lot of
the black people that i know and have
been friends with and family but we
actually care about that and
man up oh and you know what else too um
people talk about toxic masculinity what
that really mean and look i think we all
agree there is toxic masculinity in the
sense of not the term toxic masculinity
but really what that is when you talk
about the negative qualities of men
where they talk about abuse or they talk
about
aggression or bullying we're talking
about cowardly men men who beat their
wives or cowards right we're talking
about godless cowardly men who was the
first man to say be good to your wives
people get mad at christianity they go
oh they said they said wives submit to
your husbands
under the agreement that men
be good to your wives love your wives be
tender cherish your wives so when we
talk about toxic masculinity that's not
innate that's men's sinful nature where
a man is more physically powerful than a
woman and if a man abuses that power
that man is a bully right but one thing
i will say as far as actual sort of
masculine archetypes meaning the leader
of the household meaning final decision
meaning authoritative um it definitely
speaks more like black americans that's
something that is ingrained in the
culture um where i've always disagree
with it really i've always found that
that uh that with black people they r
they respect powerful male 2 which i
think is a big reason that trump got a
had a lot of appeal with black americans
i think it's within all men's nature
when
we are men yes
and so we're attracted to masculinity we
believe in but
for black people
since
the monahan report that
came out i think in
63 or something and
lyndon johnson rejected the monahan
report daniel money or
patrick moynihan
daniel patrick johnson was an actual
racist by the way yes
he was commissioned to do a study and he
came out with a study and was about
investing in the black family that
we're at a critical time and we need to
invest in the black
family
lyndon johnson rejected that yep and
went to completely different other
direction model cities yeah the great
society and
and
we're going to basically it was didn't
state it but it was going to destroy the
blacks we're going to incentivize not
getting married yes
and and
so black because of that decision and
there was a crossword were we going to
go invest in the black family are we
going to go under the destruction of it
the destruction of it has created the
black nature we have a matriarchal
culture and society among black people
yeah that's true definitely and i think
a big part of that is also because you
have a lot of fathers who aren't in the
home yeah but i'm saying black women
tend to i guess you also probably
haven't been in the what like white
liberal guys huddles like the men are
castrated black women are still
attracted to
powerful men
whereas that's often seen as a negative
in the white community now where it's
you know
sit down shut up and listen and don't
speak out and i don't think you see that
as much yeah here's what you see
repeat those words
uh sit down shut up yeah and don't speak
or something like that that's what black
women now say to black men well they
haven't been to a black movie theater
no one sits down and shuts up that's you
hear black women talking mostly
i'm just telling well that's probably
true no i'm just telling you we have a
matriarchal culture society
i'm talking about i experienced this
personally yeah but my mother doesn't
watch this but it's at the root of
tension between me and my mother
i don't say this i say this as a devoted
son my mother is one of the greatest
other than mary i don't know a better
mother than what i had
but she's a matriarch
i'm the ultimate patriarch and since
i've been paying your bills and
everything for
25 years
i really
me and my mother clash she wants to be
the matriarch i don't allow it does but
if your mom if your mom let me ask you
this if your mom were to pick a man like
a suitor i don't know if she's in a
relationship or something divorce from
my father never remarried and most of it
because
she wants to be the boss she's not she's
not a candidate but she's not going to
pick a hipster in horn rim glasses and a
onesie is my point like they're still
attractive she might she might
no i'm just she's 80 now 81 but she my
mother's going to be that doesn't mean
she doesn't still have needs i got it i
got i get that
now may you talk about that's called a
maintenance man
what kind of maintenance man she might
choose is different from a husband right
or someone she can partner with my
mother wants to be the boss yeah period
all of her friends her sister they're
all matriarchs they all they and again
this is what i like about and we haven't
even brought him up but like this kwame
brown kid that's made all this noise
yeah early spring this part of the
summer
is
he he's he's been pointing this out and
provoking a larger discussion about the
relationship between men and women and
and just
and maybe it was kevin saying but
somebody just made
the point that
being this super strong woman
as a mother
you might be creating weak men
and so in the black community there's a
big conversation among us as men like
man our culture and men have become very
emotional and very effeminate
they're modeling again it's nobody wants
to sit down and have a debate and
discussion everybody just wants to get
angry and emotional and lean into their
emotion and i'm like that ain't manly
that's not like i'm used to dealing with
emotion but not from men where you can't
control your emotion let's sit down and
talk about this chess game
and not get emotional about it yeah this
ain't a game of checkers where you just
slam the chips down they splatter
everywhere and and i may be called
yeah
i may be
called sexist or whatever but
that's a level of behavior that i
have i expect from women to be quite
honest you the emotion and feelings and
all that being more important than facts
and logic i don't expect that from a man
whoa
i can't i can't believe that you just
implied
that women are more emotional creatures
than men
yes i did no that's that's
maybe we'll end on that because that's
the kind that can get into some slippery
territory you might be wearing a hood
next but look here's one thing i will
say to go back to this at a cigar lounge
uh when i talk with
women and men and you know what's funny
you almost never see
white women smoking cigars
i do see black women smoking cigars more
than white women smoking scars and you
see a lot of black men smoking cigars
outside of like in the 80s you know the
models like demi moore would take a
picture with one when there was a boom
and fake it but
it's always a good starting point i will
say bridging the racial divide
never with politics with a stranger
but i've had a lot of conversations when
you go to a cigar lounge um just because
you happen to be sitting next to black
people white people just it's really
communal
and almost always you start talking
about church you know i start talking
about church you start talking about
faith and that builds a bridge and then
it segues into politics sometimes
and it never becomes a screaming match
because you're starting off with common
ground so that cigar sometimes is a
great unifier um and it allows you to
open up in that common ground usually
again one that you can agree on that
i've found is most successful
is our faith that bedrock that
foundation and i've had some of the best
conversations in my life all right we're
gonna go to uh mug club exclusive here a
little bit you can talk about kwame more
but the show is fearless with jason
whitlock right on the blaze yep um and
that's where you guys can go and find it
if you want to watch more where he
starts going off on
on women being more emotional and
maybe he'll talk about how white men
can't jump
all right i'm going to level with you if
you liked this video
you have to hit the share button
um
otherwise your entire family will die i
don't write the rules i just call them
and this is clipped from the live show
every monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern that's the best thing you can do
to watch life i mean you know you didn't
you you ran a fall your family's dead my
family is dead but my mother left me
with this shirt before she went home to
meet the lord oh well i guess we all
come out winners